it's in everyone's comments but all
these [ __ ] is listening right now
care more about the likes people give
them than the people behind those likes
[Music]
the hardest part is figuring out what
you want to focus on your right ladies
and gentlemen we are back with a very
very very very very special guest I
would I would argue to say your favorite
entrepreneurs favorite entrepreneur Gary
Vee thanks for having me welcome and
thanks Gary
I'm fired up yeah because of a horse
very guy well I'm gonna be honest you're
so like just like everyone's favorite
dude they're like I always say like tell
me you'd like to hear on this thing I
get a lot of good suggestions but every
time there's a Gary Vee awesome
so I want to give you the appropriate
amount of it I appreciate it yeah I'm
humbled Thank You audience yeah that's
killed us you're really connecting so
let me you know what I do on this I
usually go through people's stories
right and we have a limited amount of
time and yeah and I know you've talked
about it a lot so I want to try to kind
of get through it quick but you grew up
in Belarus yes how old were you when you
moved three so you know I didn't really
I didn't really grow I was born in
Belarus sutta I grew up in you know I
really grew up in Edison New Jersey I
spent a little time in Queens yeah
when I first came to America a studio
apartment similar to the room we're in
right now a lot of family members some
real ghetto [ __ ] huh but where I really
made my hey and like really became like
where I grew up was Edison Jersey which
was great in the 80s like super diverse
lots of like everything right Asian and
brown and black and white and there was
really really cool that way it was the
80s so everybody was outside you know
like when I was six I ate breakfast I
went outside at 8:30 9:00 I came home
for lunch I went back outside I came
home at 7:00 like and we were out and
what were you doing did you got hit in a
basketball like did you play basketball
like what was your last game later a lot
of nerf football a lot of wiffle ball a
lot of wall ball a lot of tennis for
that kind of [ __ ] but but you know as I
like to tell it and like the friends
that have were around back then
I was forced like we did Olympics we
played spud which was this weird game
where you'd hit the ball grab but like
we did kids stuff mhm but man we did a
lot of business like a lot of lemonade
sin a lot of like raking peoples you
know like leaves a lot of selling
flowers a lot of like baseball cards
like just a little like I've I've been
addicted to the game of entrepreneurship
from the get so I would say 50% of the
time it was some cockamamy and business
thing and 50% of time of that other 50
like wiffle ball and football were way
up there and was that like the other
kids were doing that too doing the the
young hustler stuff I was making them
you were okay I was definitely the force
and this is what have you ever wrapped
your head around like what drove you to
go that direction DNA like just the same
way somebody's like starts [ __ ]
drawing at 6:00 and never stops Yeah
right like the same reason somebody just
starts singing and never stops or you
know I I think there's a small group of
people call it 3 to 20 percent of people
who are just deeply passionate about
like their thing maybe it's even less
maybe 10% of people who are just like
I'm incapable of being anything else hmm
I got lucky and I hate the word luck but
like I'm living through a time where
entrepreneurship is cool mm-hmm like if
you're a businessman in 1974 like you
know the Knicks players don't think
you're cool yeah like you know in 1983
like Russell Simmons doesn't think like
that the CEO of IBM is the [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know like that's just not how it was
so what's been really crazy for me is
like I lived a life I was 30 years old
like I was 34 years old before I made
one business video in my life so I'd
already built a business my family's
liquor store business like I had already
like I lived a life I was 34 I lived a
life before all this [ __ ] started
happening um and just watching the
Entrepreneurship be put on a pedestal is
exciting and also scary I will tell you
that the number one one of the number
one fears I have is too many kids want
to be an entrepreneur even though
they're not yeah you know yeah that's
what's interesting is because like I
think that entrepreneurship is having a
moment and also you
you're like directly out in front of it
you know I mean like it's having a
moment and you are the guy you know I
mean Deuteronomy people how many
meetings I go into now and everyone now
has a camera guy oh yeah and that's
literally 100 percent I think influenced
by what you're doing but my question is
so obviously that's cool and that's the
discussion that a lot of people have on
this podcast is like yeah everyone's
allowed to preneur now and I say I think
that the good news is there will be more
real entrepreneurs out of this right
there's just going to be a lot of fakers
here to your point net yeah there are
thousands tens of thousands and I would
argue hundreds of thousands and maybe
even millions who during this era find
entrepreneurship the freedoms that come
with it
the beauty of it yeah that wouldn't have
twenty years ago because there would
have been executives what I'm worried
about is the collateral damage what do
you think happens to the person that's
caught in the crossfire I think there's
some people that commit suicide yeah I
think there's some people that you have
first and why I say that depression
because you can't hide like when your
t-shirt business fails cuz the economy
fails and influencers don't get paid
like that anymore
and [ __ ] hits the fan and you go work at
Citibank your family and friends no yeah
that you and don't forget you're the one
who you know like all this in your die
oh yeah man this is super document yeah
like you're talking [ __ ] 26 months ago
in from in front of a Lambo and now you
work at chick-fil-a corporate yeah and
that's gonna be something that's gonna
take a lot of self-esteem and humility
to get through and most people haven't
been raised with self-esteem and
humility so the reason I'm talking this
game is not to be like I'm cool and
you're not it's like yo you know what's
[ __ ] cool self-awareness yeah you know
what the [ __ ] coolest [ __ ] in the
game is forget like fresh sneakers and
forget like like a hoodie and forget
about money and forget about being a
cryptocurrency [ __ ] winner you know
what's the [ __ ] coolest
self-awareness do you do you know
yourself and then do you put yourself in
the best position to succeed yeah so
what would the advice be to summit if
someone's listening right now it was
like damn I've been talking a lot of
[ __ ] on Instagram and I'm not work for
somebody well but what I'm saying is do
you let's just say you're trying to get
your business off the ground too
to be determined whether it ends up
becoming successful now but now people
know the preneur know if listen if
you're listening right now you're like
[ __ ] I don't want I just tweeted
something that just went kind of batshit
crazy it went something like yo if
you're 22 years old and your parents pay
for any part of your lifestyle let me
define that real quick yeah if your
parents pay for your uber if your
parents pay for your gym if they're
splitting the rent with you if they pay
for your [ __ ] [ __ ] in any way does
your mommy and daddy give you a dollar
if they do and you talk [ __ ] about them
to your friends that they're not giving
you more yeah
you're the biggest piece of [ __ ] of all
time so I put that out there right and
so it's getting crazy right now and some
people are coming through they're like
yo this is the thing I'm most
embarrassed about and I'm like yo change
yeah I'm like good first of all you're
amazing because a lot of people CNN so
you [ __ ] you Gary do you have you know
yeah good you're like yes that's me
change like is it gonna be fun that you
maybe can't wear a pair of Yeezys as
often as you want is it fun that you
can't take out your girl too you know
the fanciest [ __ ] spot is it fun like
you know you want the new LeBron so you
want better tickets to the [ __ ]
playoff game or you want to get a bottle
at the club like is it fun that you
can't no but is it way better and
putting you in a position to succeed
long-term absolutely because when you're
living in a fake environment and that's
what's happening right now yeah the
thing that I'm getting most passionate
about is fake environments yeah too much
money in the system fake environment
influence getting paid for everything
like chick like that will be a that will
that is an inflated market that will
eventually have to correct yeah you know
the number one fake environment in our
society is you think you're a big shot
but your parents are actually paying for
it yeah okay so let me ask you what the
heck is this cuz this is the less that
I'm kind of gathering from that in
television real quick cuz I'm thirty
yeah I don't hate those people I hate
those people if they talk [ __ ] make
pretend they're not getting paid for or
talk [ __ ] about their parents if you
walk around like yo my parents are the
[ __ ] best
and I'm actually some I'm really
untitled but like [ __ ] it this is my
life and you own your [ __ ] I love you
yeah so that's my question is cuz you're
all about creating content and putting
everything out there is it just don't
front put everything out there but tell
the truth and say like yo today's vlog
my mom just pay my phone bill that's
dope but I'm really trying to grow yes
do people love you when you say like you
know a lot of people like you
I hear that and I'm like because I like
them first
yeah cuz I'm not trying to get like you
know me people on the internet are
faking a lifestyle so that people pay
them yeah oh yeah
the whole internet yeah like the whole
internet right now is faking a lifestyle
and then trying to sell people on like I
figured out this lifestyle you can too
when they didn't figure out that
lifestyle yeah and their business is to
make money on a new course whether
that's selling a course or selling a
product yeah I'm curious what that
correction will be there's always a
correction what's that correction when
the economy [ __ ] fails and people
look around be like yo where's the money
yeah you know everybody under 30 hasn't
been punched in the face yet yes true
that's very true like like unless you
live through that 2008 like which is now
a decade ago
you haven't been punched in the mouth
yeah and until you're punched in the
mouth you actually don't know how tough
you are true okay let me ask you this
going to the wine because I know you
took over your parents wine business yes
explain to me why first of all why why
did you take it over were they kind of
over it or just like hey I can do this
hey I can do this and my parents are the
best and I got to pay them back the
story that most people don't know about
me is I built that business from 3 to 60
and left with nothing and why because it
was my parents business so you didn't
use didn't care there was no one care
like let's not I don't want to front
yeah like it feels a little weird yeah
like you live you know first of all I
give up my 20s but the day you left you
didn't say like hey I was ready I knew
it was about to come next you didn't
want a dollar
I had no leverage like I wasn't gonna
roll up on pops and be like yo yeah tell
me and now I like rolled up on pop you
know I the time to roll on up on pops
was in the beginning yeah but I'm an
immigrant I'm an immigrant like you know
when you're a white immigrant people
don't really know your name I'm an
immigrant I wasn't born here and like
here's family immigrant businesses we
have a business whether it's a bodega or
liquor store or 7-eleven or a car wash
or whatever the [ __ ] it is we have a
business and it's mom and dad's until
they die and then you get the business
yeah that's the rules everybody and so
yeah and but honestly that worked for me
because to be very frank my number one
reason of going into the family business
was I wanted to put them on the way they
put me on I didn't want to [ __ ] and
favors my parents yeah this is why I get
so crazy about the entitlement [ __ ]
I went the other way I wanted to settle
the score my parents for putting a roof
over my head and taking me to America
from [ __ ] [ __ ] Belarus so I was
like let me just [ __ ] explode this
for them that's how it evolved and had
your relationship with them as good and
has always been good right yeah but I
would say and you know back to now
fronting there was tension between me
and my pops because couple things
happened one I'm building this huge
business and it's not mine that's weird
and I would argue that when I got into
my late 20s and early 30s that started
away on me a little bit more hmm
- I started getting a lot of Fame in the
liquor business like whiz kid and my dad
and everyone's like Gary Gary Gary store
and that started [ __ ] with my dad
he's like yo first of all it's my store
second of all like yo I came here with
nothing and like did something like what
happened to my part of the story because
it became wizkid does this and was you
know wasn't like it is now with the hole
where I've really kind of gotten some
awareness it was in this little industry
yeah but in that you know how it is
right there were your little you just
beat me to it it's your [ __ ] world
yeah and so like 80 year old dudes are
rolling I'm on my pops and be like man
your kid really put you on yeah you got
it
and my dad's got too much pride for
notch I mean if anybody ever rolls up on
me in my life and says my kids put me on
I'm gonna punch that person in the face
like that doesn't play for me and my dad
and I share a lot of competitive DNA so
luckily add a lot of empathy for my dad
and understood like yeah I wouldn't like
that either so I was able to always kind
of you know swallow my pride at times
and then ultimately like my brother was
graduating college and I was gonna start
a business with him I made a really
smart move and took money I had saved
and you know one of the things I did
really well was I lived humble as [ __ ] I
live in a [ __ ] one-bedroom apartment
Springfield New Jersey didn't cost much
I didn't get fancy moved to New York I
never went out so really easy to like
save money when you don't spend a
thousand bucks on a weekend hitting it
hard and I saved they say they say I
didn't have a lot of money but
everything I had I been on Facebook and
Twitter this is why I believe people can
win I wasn't making a lot of money I was
building business for somebody else
I I just lived humbly like everybody
wants to some kid just tweeted I put out
that tweet somebody else is like yeah
other kids like easy for you guys to say
was so much easier into 70 80s and 90s
I'm like you're a [ __ ] loser dick
wouldn't have internet [ __ ] do you know
about the 70 80s and 90s you [ __ ]
suck [ __ ] like like it's not
easier you're just lazy and entitled cuz
mommy and daddy did everything for you
and you think life's about playing
[ __ ] xbox and smoking weed and
[ __ ] drinking Mountain Dew Korra
[ __ ] [ __ ] go work yeah let me see
this what did you I'm bringing the
collateral from the tweet I just suck
everybody who's listening I'm sorry
sixteen minutes ago I saw a tween like
this kid literally thinks the 70 80s and
90s was harder yeah are you [ __ ]
kidding me the Internet's the best every
[ __ ] listening right now can go go to
Alibaba buy some [ __ ] flip it on
Amazon and eBay and make money yeah
every dick listening right now has a
thousand dollars worth of [ __ ] [ __ ]
in their home that they'll never use
again do you understand if you put that
dartboard on eBay you'd get seven bucks
yeah absolutely
but hey I'm not the one in your tweets I
get it but because the other thing yes
are you looking at everything in this
was this a bunch of renter's there's
$8,000 in here yeah cuz those Nikes are
probably worth a fortune
yeah this place is like a little eBay
let me because this is everything I was
gonna say is you must get the worst of
all of those type of social media
comments you know what I'm saying
because I get the best and the worst
true but I guess they're exposing
everyone's like the regular ones this
biggest reason no a lot of people don't
like me at first is I'm I'm poking at
the thing they don't want anybody to
know about that and then it's like [ __ ]
you dude huh yep yeah and I'm like I do
but like you dwelling and blaming your
parents your neighborhood society the
government it's not going to do anything
for you yeah
complaining and entitlement is just like
it's it's poison yeah and so for me it's
like and this is why I get the best I
get the I get [ __ ] DMS that make my
head spin like sure yo bro look [ __ ]
like this yo bro uh so yeah I was
hitting my girl before I started
watching your [ __ ] and you've made me a
better man and I don't do that no more
and I make money the right way like you
know under that yeah I'm like all right
first of all like cool and never hit
your girl again to like awesome and
three like don't get don't get flashy
now just cuz you made your first
thousand bucks flipping something on
Craig's by the way do you know much
money I've made for people telling them
to go to
Craigslist [ __ ] for free and then flip
it wasn't that kind of the first big
thing that really broke through to like
the masses it was you know what it was
it wasn't that I will say this I was on
The Breakfast Club I remember that and
MB came at me and he was like yo
whatever like like stop being like were
like stop yeah motive I like that give
me something of tangible and I was like
oh [ __ ] you know cuz it's like no I was
like you came at me like your brain goes
fast and I'm like well the most tangible
thing I know the thing I was if I went
to zero tomorrow yeah coma my face got
ripped off I have a new face I'm in
Alaska like what the [ __ ] just happened
this is a nightmare no this is my new
life cool I don't complain and the first
thing I do is like I find [ __ ] the flip
like the number one thing that gets
everybody out of zero is selling
something yeah and I think like
everybody wants to build like the next
off-white and I'm like yo before you get
to the next off-white before you tell me
that you're [ __ ] you know gonna be
the next [ __ ] champion why don't you
learn how to go to Goodwill buy some
t-shirts for a dollar and sell them for
eleven and get your [ __ ] together cuz in
your email you also said that you have
17 dollars and you want me to give you
$10,000 but that thing's just gone right
that that Breakfast Club clip was just
ha ha yeah I mean Breakfast Club no
question became we started the process
it was interesting it was happening in
parallel Breakfast Club and I brought
Mike Boyd closer to my team not just at
vaynermedia because I wanted to it was
it's just very into me the culture music
like I started listening to more
emerging artists it's amazing how it
actually works
yeah Breakfast Club and me spending a
lot more time on Soundcloud and you know
artists and just in general this sneaker
thing was in the background that I
wanted to do with k-swiss
like it was just like all happening and
veiners getting more mature so I know
I'm ready to buy [ __ ] so brands I want
to market to fifteen to thirty youth
keeps you young I love it I feel younger
at 42 than I ever in my life because I'm
just in it it's cool yeah okay so let me
ask you this
back to the story part of it so you
build this business up to sixty million
that's from like doing the YouTube stuff
doing better marketing right email
Google AdWords even direct mail and
radio and television just a great
marketer a great operator I'm a
this man vaynermedia Manor acts with
pure Wow and 137 p.m. now that's a 200
million dollar enterprise I built from
scratch like a good businessman you know
like I think people forget that a little
bit yeah I like that part a little bit I
think I think I like being
underestimated and I think the explosion
of garyvee in the last 18 months has a
lot of people under estimating how much
of a businessman I am NOT just a
personnel yeah yeah it's gonna benefit
you later a hundred percent I mean and
you know what I'm just asked this
question at least when I wrote down one
thing that you wrote that I thought was
really dope was I said or something was
uh everyone said you were the wine guy
until you weren't yeah what is everyone
saying that you are now I think a lot of
not I think 50% of the people in the
world think I'm a motivational speaker
yeah and what will you how would they
see you differently in 10 years that was
one of the greatest businessmen of all
time who happened to be motivational
yeah and honestly I let me say it a
different way I think I will be one of
the most respected like entrepreneurs
ever mm-hmm and I'll tell you why I
don't know if I'm gonna make the most
let me phrase I'm not gonna make the
most money right
Elon Musk and sucks uh Bezos and Meg
Whitman there's there's tons of people
that are you know gonna do it bigger uh
what what I think I'm gonna do is give
back more to the game you know the
people that are really in the
billionaire girls boys club they're not
in the trenches like I am mm-hmm they're
not spitting [ __ ] he may flip tactics
they're not they're not doing podcast
because they know they're gonna reach
different people they're not they're not
in it yeah they're in their ivory towers
yeah in their [ __ ] you know to this
morning 6:00 a.m. I did a little snap
just sit at the airport I mean [ __ ] a
hundred people like you know why don't
you fly private yo don't you have a
[ __ ] club like membership with all
the miles you put in yeah and I replied
I'm like my do I'm like but it's fine
sitting here to like like I'm not
[ __ ] fancy yeah and do you think it
keeps you hungry because I all I'm gonna
be honest yeah I don't consider myself
very fancy I've been doing this a long
time yeah flying private is one of the
things
I would just love to be able to do and
my question is more practical
yeah and I've definitely flown private
more in the last year that I have in my
whole life because it saves me time and
time is valuable you know to me it's
like if I don't have to fly private
I definitely don't I'm not [ __ ] who my
[ __ ] flying private for yeah yeah
I'll be honest with you how about this I
flew to can private the other day yeah
and it sucked because the beds in
first-class American make a flat bed and
the private [ __ ] is kind of still a
little bit old school it was a [ __ ]
trillion-dollar plane but it was still
not a [ __ ] bed the way I liked it and
I was like [ __ ] I wish I went [ __ ]
American yeah yeah yeah I get it I get
it okay so let me sorry let me let me
just stay on that one I have a great
sense of who listens to this if you were
doing anything because you give a [ __ ]
about what the other person's seeing it
thinks you are losing agreed
it's not about for me here that's why me
to you that's it by the way what so if
you're flying private cuz you love it
somebody my high he loves limos and I
know he does yeah so my good you you win
Yeah right like to me your point that's
why I made that point yeah yeah if you
want to fly private if you fly private
because your times become so valuable
smart if you blab private because [ __ ]
it it makes you super happy like your
dream of dreams is like this just makes
me [ __ ] smile in my stomach
then good but if you fly private because
you want to put that Instagram photo up
yeah and you want to project a persona
it's going in the wrong direction you're
tied up in the wrong things and so you
just genuinely at the core of you don't
give a [ __ ] about this being on an
American lay flat not that part right
like I give a [ __ ] about being liked
which is why people like me yeah like I
genuinely give a [ __ ] about being liked
so that's why I build a real community
that's why I'm putting up good [ __ ] I
genuinely don't want to spend money on
things that I don't value so for example
if I value my health like I did four
years ago I have a full-time trainer he
flies with me it cost me money to fly my
trainer to LA and workout this morning a
[ __ ] Equinox like I did it like you
know I'm spending money but I'm spending
money on what Matt
- Mia and and for example I don't even
talk that much about having a trainer
that travels with me I have a funny
feeling the people I'm referencing in
this thing if they had a trainer
traveling with them they'd have a post
of that every time be like hey Rick
wasn't awesome to be in Mexico I paid
for rec to be in Mexico because I'm a
baller you [ __ ] [ __ ]
so when you obviously undeniably you're
one of the best at the the best at this
new media style of even being an
entrepreneur yes
and documenting and connecting and you
know what I'm saying yeah when you
started this did you have this grand
plan or was it like this just needs to
be documented and this whole thing kind
of snowball we start
d-roc reached out to me wanted to make a
film I was ready vein ER was finally in
a place where I was ready to make
content again because in 2012 to 14 I
was kind of head down d-roc hits me up
because I wanna make a film for you I'm
like you know what yeah cool let's do it
makes a film I really like it I really
like him he's a good kid I'm like you
know what I've been dying to do this Q&A
show called I loved speaking speaking
was working for me and I was like you
know what would be rad if I just did Q&A
mm-hmm cuz that's where I'm my best like
if you asked me where I'm at my best
it's Q&A so I was like man I'm gonna do
a show about QA that may parlay into me
being able to just do Q&A he knows that
was the master plan together so I hired
the rock full time we start a youtube
show called the askgaryvee show and it
starts popping a little bit at the same
token Casey and others have the vlog
thing going first person oh right yep
and D rocks like one of these [ __ ]
you know video nerds like Babb and all
these [ __ ] kids they love this [ __ ]
they grew up with it they loved Casey
they loved all the [ __ ] yeah and he's
like you have to do this you have this
I'm like dude I'm not [ __ ] walking
around with a camera in my hand and
somewhere somehow some moment I'm like
you should follow me around and I
remember sitting on it actually for a
little bit cuz I said oh that's super
douchey like am I really gonna go like
reality TV on the world without like
really doing reality TV yeah I'm like
that may not play but then finally back
to not giving a [ __ ] yeah I was like I'm
gonna be right and a lot of people gonna
do this in two years and I'm gonna be
the UM you just did it for me you
literally literally in the start of this
episode did what I knew would happen
three years ago which is I'm gonna get
credit for starting a trend and
everybody's gonna do because it makes
sense it's a good idea yeah and let me
tell you why it's not just a good idea
for building your brand and all that
it's a good idea cuz it's gonna be fun
to look at when you're [ __ ] old yeah
like I can't wait to watch [ __ ] when
babban 73 and looks like [ __ ]
I'm like dude you were so young at 20
look at you you're [ __ ] amazing like
you know it's gonna be a I mean all the
cool [ __ ] I did in 2005 to 2010 I to
Facebook when there was 300 employees
that'd be cool to reference like I was
super right about Instagram being a
steal for a billion dollars I have one
lucky moment on CNN where I'm like
talking that [ __ ] but I would have had
three months of talking that [ __ ] you
know like like I'm gonna be right about
voice right and in seven years when
voice and everybody's trying to figure
out their voice strategy and her Alexis
skills and all that I'm like yo look at
the recall in 2018 when I [ __ ]
predicted this [ __ ] and then people are
like oh [ __ ] like it just works and then
most of all my grandkids are gonna be
like hey grandpa you know Gary like I
talk like you or I have that mannerism
or I make that smirk or that's why
little Sally [ __ ] does that thing and
that's just like why do we look looking
at pictures of our grandparents this is
way better yeah yeah I get it if you're
let's just paint a picture of one day
you're a billionaire you're the owner
the Jets up in the box
yep killing it is babban with you
vlogging it yeah but a problem will be
bamming cuz BAM is probably gonna be
accepting his third Academy Award sure
the nice babbit I'm saying is that
vlogging I'm go home now until yes I
think so yeah I mean look anything can
happen something bad you know something
tragic can happen in my life my mom
could tragically die tomorrow and I
might just shut down for a while or who
knows right or something new happens or
what have you but I see non-business
value in vlogging I see personal family
heritage [ __ ] you know how do you get to
the billion dollar multi-billion dollar
Jets owner I guess what I'm saying how
am i planning on doing it from my
perspective right and this is really
another one like my questions to you is
I see what you're doing
kind of yep and and you have all of
these different things from the agency
to the new companies they whatever and
you now have this added icing level of
Fame yeah lack of a better word in
connection yep
what do you do we all take that to that
level I Prince the tennis racquet
business yeah I convert it into a
sneaker and hoodie brand I run it
through the Vayner and garyvee machine i
buy it for two hundred eight million
because now I'm building big businesses
I can afford it and I sell it for 2.7
billion to adidas cuz they need the more
contemporary brand i buy Cracker Jacks
for a hundred million I flip it for a
billion I think the what I did smart was
I deployed self-awareness eight years
ago and said I have to build a machine
that's the scalable version of me yeah
so that when I buy smart water on the
decline when I buy Rolling Rock the beer
when I buy this [ __ ] this thing that I
will become the CEO of so my executives
have baynard's somebody will become the
CEO right Andre will become the CEO
marcus japanese like somebody's gonna
become a CEO and then i will be the CEO
of a business that i buy for a couple
hundred million that i will sell for two
billion and i'll be off to the races
is that what pure Wow is pure was
actually part of the machine you know so
that's publishing right 1:37 p.m. now a
male's brand that's part of the machine
because I'll use those entities too big
whatever the [ __ ] I care about there's
no brand yet and what do you know now it
was your are you constantly looking
right now yeah but everything's
expensive because the economy's too
fluffy yeah so you know what I need
everybody to go work at Citibank buy it
yeah I'm I'm I'm like a snake in the
grass right now which is crazy cuz I'm
loud as [ __ ] right now yeah but in my
head I'm incognito right now yeah which
is why I know I've won if everybody
thinks I've won or I'm winning right now
and I think I'm dog [ __ ] right now and
I'm still laying low and I'm like and
I'm just jockeying and putting the
pieces together
well then I'm [ __ ] coming out like a
phoenix in 2024 that's why I see from my
perspective I see and obviously we've
been involved in TV and all these
different things right so I see what
you've done I see the platform you've
now built I see it not as at the height
I see it as like all right you're lined
up to do the thing what's it what is it
you know I can't wait to see the net
and it might be IP you know like I might
buy like Snorks Myra Snorks those
[ __ ] like you gotta be old kids most
of people listen now like gonna have to
google it yeah Snorks were like under
the water Smurfs
back in 84 cartoon yeah okay so I'm
gonna buy some old IP maybe I don't know
but I'm gonna buy something and flip it
got it cuz that's what I do whether its
buying [ __ ] he-man toys for eight
bucks at a garage sale and flipping it
for 42 we're buying some wine and
flipping it or baseball cards I've been
that's what I do I'm just gonna have one
big [ __ ] flip yeah another big one I
think a lot of people know that will
wrap it up after this is uh what are you
the one thing is you don't you vlog your
[ __ ] ass off you are constantly
creating content but you don't you can
tell there's a massive side of your life
that doesn't show my family family right
do you is it like you're working all day
but when the clock is up it's time to go
you wrap it up you go home and you're
just well either Gary know the weekends
and seven weeks vacation but Monday
through Friday yeah I'm getting home at
11:30 at night there is no father so
they just know they're wait until the
weekend yeah we we're playing an extreme
game at least that's what it is now yeah
it works for me and my family working
for my wife's family so it's a little
bit more native to us I'm sure for some
people that's crazy yeah I respect that
everybody should do it their way so
that's what's going on and then on the
flip side we're not showing the family
because it's a we made a family decision
that like you know my wife and kids like
we're gonna keep that separate and and
you know it's already been hard because
I'm getting recognized so much more in
public when I'm with them but it's
definitely it's been very conscious and
that doesn't bother you like you're the
one thing that kills me or gets me is
you're going to everywhere you go you're
doing meetups you're doing like you it
seems like you genuinely love the energy
the connection that you don't get tired
you don't get worn out of like man I
just want to go to the mall with my
family and not be recognized um no you
don't I really like babban right that's
the coolest part right like I get more
energy yeah
100% right
yeah it's tough man I've even had times
you know what I just gotta love yous I'm
a grateful yeah I can't get over the
gratitude yeah like there's no tired or
annoyed or struggling with something
that that person doesn't know about yeah
that trumps the gratitude of somebody
being like holy [ __ ] you're Gary Vee you
bring you understand a very important
thing about me my micro Fame emerging
Fame comes not because I'm [ __ ] hot
not because I can spit bars yeah not
because I can put a ball in a whoo via
my fame is coming because I'm bringing
people emotional and mental value that
then maybe maybe they act on which then
makes their life better there is a
different level of relationship and it
and I'm it's nice if you like me yeah
I've done something nice for you yeah
I've gotten you to be less insecure I've
gotten you to finally tell your parents
to go [ __ ] themselves I've gotten you to
like do the thing you've been dying to
do I've gotten you to put your your
situation in perspective here's my big
thing if you've heard me you're already
in a good spot yeah yeah like if you've
ever heard me it means you have internet
smartphone yeah like go sell your phone
like like you know like so you're ready
in a decent spot and so my big thing is
perspective like you could be dead you
could be not alive at all you could like
whatever you my mom and I appreciate you
know I know you're I'm gonna hard stop
but I'm enjoying it now so I'll give us
a couple more minutes I appreciate you
appreciate your energy yeah my mom lost
her mom when she was five yeah her mom
died my mom was being raised in the
Soviet Union let me just break it down
for everybody bad like bad 19 [ __ ] 62
Soviet Union it it's bad like I know
Mississippi's bad I know there's a lot
of places that are bad in America it's
bad like Stalin was killing everybody
like like killing everybody okay next
her dad then goes to jail for a decade
for being Jewish
that's how it rolled in the Soviet Union
listen we got real [ __ ] race problems
and gender problems in America
forget about Supreme Court you're mad at
them right now or all this other [ __ ]
like in Russia you just got scooped up
and sent to Siberia so now our dad's
ghost
she's also living in one of the small
Jewish towns in Russia post-world War
two where everybody blame Jews for World
War two so all the millions that died
yeah that's your fault and Grandpa after
after he lost his wife after my mom lost
her mom he goes a little bit like
gangster and marries like a young
non-jewish girl which is like a scandal
in all of town so now mom lost her mom
dad's in jail and she's being raised by
young non-jewish woman which ostracizes
her from the whole environment and her
five year your older brother is really
her five year younger brother right my
mom then has a kid at twenty moves to
America with nothing her husband has to
work the next 15 years every minute
never sees him and raises three kids
with no help we go in one family
vacation my whole life my mom never
complained once mm-hmm so when I sit
here I'm like why do I get so pissed
that people complain and by the way
babban you've been with you I've never
really said this in this way so I'm glad
I'm saying on your podcast on the point
to it make sure everybody listens in now
I know why I hate complaining because if
my mom doesn't complain who the [ __ ] are
you yeah and you've always been that way
and I've always been that way without
realizing it got it because for the [ __ ]
psychoanalyzing themselves in their teen
or 20s I mean realize it when all this
attention started coming in people's
yeah yeah yeah yeah I started you know
in the last five seven years I'm like
wait a minute what the why am i
connecting like this what the [ __ ] am i
Oprah like you know like you know like
you know later you know [ __ ] ya Beaupre
goddamnit like you know and I push
against it which is good like I don't
want to make my money on my audience
which is the biggest thing that happened
to me was that I knew how to make money
outside of the people that listened to
me which is game-changing you know which
is why people [ __ ] with me they know I
don't want their money
I want the
tension for a very limited time so I can
reframe their [ __ ] brain to make them
realize how good it is and how capable
they are I want to basically undo all
the [ __ ] their parents and friends
did to give them insecurities shed some
light on yo you're mad that you [ __ ]
went to college and can't get a job what
about going to Kmart buying things on
closeout and selling it on eBay like
like I'm not joking about this
you know like I think people like I
don't think people really understand how
deeply religious I am about this which
is you are 100% in control you don't
like America move to Sweden yeah yeah
yeah I get it anyway my man sitting and
talking to you right interesting why
about like because I watch a lot of your
stuff and I really like I like a lot of
it ya know and I know you can be loved
which I appreciate I do it and in real
life it just you can no I'm not saying I
don't want to come off wrong I'm not
saying I've ever questioned it instead I
go this is a but it closed the final but
we're not sit and talk with you you can
tell that it's not it's not a character
right like and just something about like
just actually the way that you say it
yeah but that's what everybody asks you
right like am i real in real life that's
the number one question right well sure
I bet I can see why but I'm just saying
that I think that like really sitting
and talking you it's like damn like you
genuinely it's in your eyes it's in the
way you know I mean like you really you
know what's really cool my high school
junior high college friends they're the
most excited cuz like man you were like
this when there was none of this yeah
yeah meaning like before the Internet
yeah like you were the nicest kid in our
junior high trying to like amp up the
biggest nerd and art like this is real
stories I get like this is weird
yeah like you were just nice and you
didn't give a f--- like like you took
elves from popular kids to protect nerds
cuz wow you actually the oh now I get it
you didn't give a [ __ ] yeah
and to me like life now is way easier
than high school you know when this [ __ ]
was hard when the high school ecosystem
didn't reward kindness yeah high school
sucks hiker school sucks and there's
hierarchy but I spit in the face of like
the most popular kids in my high school
first of all they liked me yeah cuz I
liked them but anytime they went to that
place where they weren't nice and I
wasn't tough it wasn't like I was gonna
fight
I would just make snarky comments back
like I knew I knew how to play
psychological warfare yeah you know what
I mean I knew how to poke their
insecurities yeah
look you're mad at Joel because Becky
broke up with you yeah and then another
guy I swing it quick
what about casca oh god what a help to
me it appears that the case with ya
yes is outside of your bigger strategy
outside of my bigger strike meaning
right if your bigger strategy is
building this up not worrying about
monetizing fans but bringing on brands
building up whatever what was the
strategy behind its the preview it's
just to see if you could do it of course
yeah it's the preview and you yeah yeah
k-swiss was [ __ ] will go down as a
thing that everybody looks back at and
be like oh [ __ ] mmm-hmm he was cutting
his teeth on that mm-hmm
so for you that's like can I sell
product oh but not me yeah it meaning
Gary Vee yeah but k-swiss is getting
lifted overall yeah yeah yeah I get it
that's just a question I had can i watch
that I'm trying to obviously and you
know why didn't work a Swiss coz they
were at zero yeah did you take equity
nope I didn't even need to make a good
deal I needed to see like if I did it
with something that was further along I
wouldn't have been able to unwind if it
was my impact or if it was just cruising
yeah got it yeah yeah so I had to go
with something that gave me freedom and
really was gonna Bank on me yeah because
I feel like you deserve equity and you
know what else is air pods yes so many
fake Gary bees with their paws man it is
incredible
I will tell you those are the fun things
about documenting if you look at the
early days I dare pods day one
everyone's [ __ ] on them I'm
co-signing it heavy and everybody
there's so many beings and air pods so
the cameraman welcome by the way and you
know what's crazy about that it's just
that most hunk like I'm just like what
because I never pandered to cool my
whole life yeah back to high school and
everything yeah to watch nuances of cool
and I don't think I'm the coolest but I
definitely understand what's happening
but bro you're I'm like no I know it's
really cool
okay then the end yeah go ahead you I'm
gonna flip this in a different way you
you do askgaryvee yes people call in
they ask you all sorts questions when
you turn their life around let's just go
back in time your young Gary be running
around New Jersey flippin lemonade
stands and all this [ __ ] you call
askgaryvee and say hey mans right then
you can tell me like I'm really hungry
out here I really want to be a
big-league entrepreneur what do I do
how what takes the edge off of some of
my extra worry yeah extra what can you
tell me old Gary so a couple things I
would love you know what I wish is I
lived in the era where chemicals in
one's body were readable in real time if
you like yeah I'm gonna say it really
nice and slow because I know it's weird
as [ __ ] yeah if you knew what was
happening in my body as you were asking
that question I could feel the warmth of
my chemicals yeah the thought that young
Gary would ever call old Gary is
inconceivable why cuz young Gary didn't
want to take advice from anybody
there was no insecurities yeah it was
100% tilt I know what the [ __ ] I'm doing
no one's my mentor the game is my mentor
yeah the process is my mentor you still
feel a hundred percent yeah I would I
learn by doing yeah I don't need
somebody's advice not my dad's not my
mom's not not [ __ ] Elon Musk not
[ __ ] Warren Buffett I don't want it
I'll tell you why not because I don't
[ __ ] respect it I respect anybody
that's I respect anyone who's trying
everybody out there who's trying I
respect you it's not how I learn the
reason I am Who I am is I listen to
people mm-hmm meaning feedback a hundred
percent yeah the reason I love that
person rolling up at me babban at 11:37
p.m. after a [ __ ] 23 hour day is cuz
I'm gonna learn something from the way
they feel and what are they gonna say
why do they [ __ ] with me the reason I
read all my comments and engage and I
know what to make you know why know how
to make the next piece of content they
told me mm-hmm
it's in my comments it's in everyone's
comments but all these [ __ ] is
listening right now care more about the
likes people give them than the people
behind those likes and that is the
[ __ ] mistake there it is man I was
good solid ending like
[Music]